[Musique]
avec vos hélène frade bonjour à la
bouche avant de parler de la visite de
philippe roi des belges en rdc dans la
presse internationale la flambée des
prix des matières premières et de
l'énergie une hausse des cours enclenché
après la crise sanitaire hélène et qui
s'est accéléré avec la guerre en ukraine
mais les prix records du gaz du pétrole
des métaux et des céréales menace
désormais l'économie et la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale alerte ce matin le
figaro en prévenant que cette flambée
n'est probablement pas terminée alors
que vous l'avez dit les ministres des
affaires étrangères russe et turque
doivent discuter aujourd'hui de la mise
en place de corridors sécurisés en mer
noire pour exporter les céréales
craignent n kiev tente de contourner ce
bloc le blocus russe en passant
notamment par des porcs roma mais ces
palliatifs restent insuffisants face aux
risques de famine dans certains pays
d'après libération qui cite le cas de
l'egypte premier importateur mondial de
blé dont 80% en provenance de russie et
d'ukraine comment éviter une famine qui
pourrait toucher des millions de gens
comment rouvrir la mer noire où des
centaines de mines ont été déposées à la
fois par la russie et l'ukraine le
journal suisse le temps parle d'une
question en passe de se transformer en
l'une des plus brûlants dans les
relations entre l'ukraine et ses alliés
occidentaux
le blé ukrainien prisonniers des mines
en mer noire c'est à voir aussi enfin
avec ce dessin dessins de oussama hajjaj
publié par le quotidien panarabe de
londres alquds alarabi où les grains de
blé on le voit ont été remplacés par des
mines
dans la presse internationale également
hélène on l'a dit à l'instant la visite
qui a commencé il ya quelques heures du
roi des belges en république
démocratique du congo une visite une
visite pour tourner la page ce
déplacement très symbolique du souverain
belge dans l'ancienne colonie fait la
une du soir auquel le premier ministre
alexander de croo a expliqué que si la
belgique et la rdc veulent travailler
comme de vrais partenaires je le cite
qui peuvent se regarder droit dans les
yeux alors ils doivent affronter le
passé un passé omniprésent dans les
esprits des deux peuples selon le
quotidien congolais le potentiel
le journal salue la démarche du roi des
belges il a courageusement reconnu les
erreurs commises pendant la colonisation
au congo mais il prévient que les
congolais ont d'autres préoccupations
actuellement la guerre civile la crise
économique et la corruption notamment et
qu'ils veulent entendre je cite toujours
un autre discours que ce stéréotypé et
protocolaire habituel à propos de
corruption mais dans un autre domaine
hélène l'ouverture aujourd'hui en suisse
du procès de sa blatter et de michel
platini notamment jugé pour escroquerie
n'a le temps évoque des retrouvailles
amères pour ce duo qui a régné sur le
foot mondial de 1998 à 2015 de
dirigeants qui ont été longtemps alliées
avant de devenir ennemis et qui sont
tous les deux accusés d'avoir obtenu
illégalement au détriment de la fifa un
paiement de 2 millions de francs suisses
soit à peu près deux millions d'euros en
faveur de michel platini sepp blatter et
michel platini désormais face à leurs
juges le journal l'équipe souligne que
gianni infantino l'actuel patron de la
fifa et ancien bras droit de michel
platini à l'uefa a été le grand
bénéficiaire politique dans cette
affaire in fantino at il profité en
toute innocence d'un parfait strike ou
at il obtenu tenu un rôle beaucoup plus
obscurs dans les chutes conjuguées de
blatter et platini s'interroge le
quotidien sportif il y a à ce stade
aucun élément matériel connu montrant
que gianni infantino or est vrai contre
michel platini tranche pour sa part le
site d'info mediapart qui se demande lui
pourquoi cette blatter a accepté de
verser 2 millions à michel platini en
2011 en janvier 2011 d'après le site
d'info lassus de la justice suisse
soupçonne sans avoir pu le prouver
jusqu'à présent que l'ancien patron de
la fifa aurait voulu s'assurer que
michel platini ne se présenterait pas
contre lui à la présidence de la fifa
quelques mois plus tard à propos de
relations compliquées hélène un mot de
l'affrontement en france entre jean luc
mélenchon le chef de la minuk baisse la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale et le gouvernement sur la
gestion du maintien de l'ordre tout ça à
quelques jours des élections
législatives après le fiasco de la
finale de la ligue des champions au
stade de france et la mort par balle
samedi à paris de la passagère d'un
véhicule dont le conducteur avait refusé
d'obtempérer les forces de l'ordre sont
la cible on entend des critiques du
patron de la france insoumise qui a
déclaré lundi je le cite sur les réseaux
sociaux que la police tue ces propos ont
en effet allumé la mèche d'un débat
virulent avec l'exécutif sur le maintien
de l'ordre à quelques jours en effet du
premier tour des législatives le monde
évoque une opération réussie du point de
vue politique en tout cas puisque le
gouvernement est monté au front pour
répliquer à jean luc mélenchon à un
moment les sondages font craindre aux
maquereaux nist l'obtention d'une simple
majorité relative à l'issue de ces
législatives à cause de la dynamique
créée par l'union de la gauche la
fameuse du ps
avant de dire adieu à leur pauline
voulais partager avec vous cette petite
lueur d'espoir sur le fond de la lutte
contre le cancer le new york times fait
état des résultats prometteurs d'un
petit essai clinique i et a été réalisée
sur dix-huit personnes atteintes de
cancer colorectal dont sacharow temps
qu'on aperçoit ici à l'image il ya deux
ans cette femme de 38 ans à l'époque et
17 autres malades ont été soignés avec
un médicament pendant six mois à l'issue
de ce traitement leur cancer ont
totalement disparu il n'y a à ce jour
aucun cas de récidive connu et c'est
absolument sans précédent
on pense à tous ceux qui sont en lutte
merci beaucoup et l'aisne à tout à
l'heure